[Music]
you're looking at live pictures in Eagle
Pass Texas that is the Border area much
under dispute right now tensions ramping
up this week between Texas governor Greg
Abbott and the White House over the
administration's response there at the
southern border and now after multiple
hearings over dare election of Duties
House Republicans are set to move
forward with articles of impeachment
even a housewi vote to actually impeach
DHS secretary Alejandra meerus joining
me now to discuss Texas Republican
Congressman Michael McCall welcome back
to Fox News Sunday thanks foram all
right so we have brand new here the two
articles of impeachment willful and
systemic uh refusal to comply with the
law and breach of the public trust now
is he just the messenger carrying out
the policies for the administration why
go after him when this may go nowhere in
the Senate uh he knows better and I I I
you know I S chairman Homeland Security
when Jay Johnson he was the deputy he
was a US attorney in Los Angeles uh he
knows better this is not by accidents by
Design and he I call him the architect
of Destruction U 8 million encounters uh
300 on the terror watch list 200 million
people dead now thanks to fentel
poisoning that this one man is
responsible for I think that is a der
elction of Duty and you know we looked
at the founding fathers here they didn't
have a lot of Federal Criminal statutes
breach of the public trust is is
sufficient to impeach and U you know I
think it's important that we respond to
the American people all right here's a
response from a democratic Congressman
colleague of yours Jake aenl was on Fox
yesterday here's what he
said impeachment is grossly
inappropriate for policy differences if
Republicans are serious about border
policy then let's engage on this
bipartisan border policy Bill impeaching
secretary myor is an admission by the
GOP in the house that they don't
actually have plans they just have anger
you're
angry yeah my constituents are angry I
just got back from Texas I was down at
the border I saw it's worse than it's
ever been Shannon the detention spaces
are overflowing again and all they you
know notice to appear and they're let
into our society it's unsustainable and
it's causing so injurious to the state
is what the founding fathers said this
is a greatest injury I think I've seen
and it was really because of the change
in policy by executive Fiat uh and
changing executive orders from the
previous administration I love the fact
we're going to try to do legislation up
here but the fact is President Biden can
change this tomorrow if he just changed
uh the executive orders they did on day
one remain in Mexico came out of my
committee and it simply says you're
detained but you remain in Mexico
pending the adjudication of political
Asylum therefore catch and release is
over and it stopped and it secured the
Border this President could do the same
thing but he chooses not to okay quickly
if the Senate deal comes to together but
it's DOA and the house as we keep
hearing will the House vote on some
measure for Ukrainian Aid that's not
attached to the Border or does it have
to be a deal package deal for you I mean
um you know that's gone back and forth
and you know you know that's kind of a
leadership question I I could see it
tied to maybe Israel and Indo Pacific um
you know I my thoughts you know on
Ukraine I think we can't abandon our
allies and surrender to Putin and
Ukraine like we did in Afghanistan but
maybe border splits apart from those po
it seems to me that that that's of
course things are currently I don't know
if the Senate version is going to be
sufficient in the house I don't know if
speaker Johnson will put it on the floor
unless it has significant policy changes
like the ones I'm talking about and we
don't have the text yet so we'll see
there's a lot of pressure as okay so
let's talk about this given your foreign
policy connection as well um this UN
agency that we fund to the tune of
billions of dollars with us funds it's
supposed to help people um within the
Gaza Strip and be Beyond there are
accusations that several of the
employees Were Somehow directly involved
in the massacres the terror attacks on
October 7th we remind the countries that
have suspended funding to them um but
there has long been a history of
questions and problems about their
activity how do we get Aid to people in
the region who desperately needed
civilians and you know also decide how
we're going to hold this agency
accountable well you do it through other
NOS like the world food program and
others I mean the the United Nations
relief agency uh the pre previous Trump
Administration cut all funding for a
reason just for this reason the idea
that unra was actually supplying uh you
know harboring weapons to assist with
hamas's invasion of Israel now those are
the allegations that have come out of
Israel we're investigating but if true
think how outrageous that is and we do
have reporting that unor is using money
to give Aid to amas um and that's why
I've advocated to cut that funding the
administration finally
after they allowed it put a pause on it
uh just a couple days ago uh this is and
they're going to testify before my
committee and we're going to get some
answers okay another foreign policy
issue bipartisan group of house members
wrote a a letter to the president on
Friday about the strikes on the houy um
targets all that's going on in the Red
Sea they say this we believe the US
unauthorized strikes in Yemen violate
the constitution we urge your
Administration to seek authorization
from Congress they say it's up to
Congress debating putting US troops US
dollars in line with attacks like these
where are you on this well this this
goes back to the authorization of use of
military force my committee would pass
this right now they're using article to
self-defense right whoy Rebels they've
shut down the Red Sea by the way uh you
know 450% increase in shipping going
through there so inflation energy but
the bottom line is uh to some extent I
agree the Congress should authorize but
I would authorize I in fact in my aumf
proposal we we authorized uh use of
force against not uh the these Iranian
proxies not Iran itself but the proxies
of Iran that's what's changed since 911
houy Rebels are causing so much
destruction and this projection of
weakness that this Administration has
whether it be you know with Russia China
and the Ayatollah has brought this on
all right we'll see if the White House
does come to you on this Mr chairman
always good to see you thanks thanks for
coming in I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme
and I'm me airart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis